we got a lot to cover this morning and
for an in-depth look we're joined by
Kathleen Kingsbury deputy editorial page
editor of the New York Times Kathleen
good morning hi good morning
let's start with fire and fury since it
seems to be what everybody is talking
about and the president was tweeting
rather late last night for him about
this about this book and particularly
about his former chief strategist Steve
Bannon who's at the heart of this
account of the White House how how
significant do you think is the fallout
from the breakup of this relationship I
think what the fallout is really still
to be determined
Bannon is clearly the one who is
suffering the most right now we've seen
people like the Mercer's his financial
backers already start to distance
themselves the future of his website
Breitbart really it's remains to be seen
but I think we're gonna see more in the
next weeks there the revelations in this
book if if they are accurately reported
are scathing as far as the president's
fitness for office michael wolf is on
national television saying president
Trump has lost it is there a
reconciliation that needs to happen in
the Republican Party as far as this is
concerned I think that yes absolutely
that said I think that this book while
it lays out incredible details
particularly details directly from the
White House and quotes staffers in ways
that we haven't heard before
it really does echos a lot of the
reporting that we've heard over the last
year you know the president has been
erratic since he came into office you
know a lot of the concerns right now are
how do we minimize the damage
particularly on the world stage well so
how big a threat do you think it poses
on the world stage um you know we're
talking about nuclear war with North
Korea right now do we really want the
North Koreans to think that this is a
president who is impatient and unwilling
to have dialogue no absolutely not
you know we're seeing South Korea make
efforts at trying to reach out to the
north so the the u.s. really needs to
back that effort let's turn the page a
little bit to more White House intrigue
the New York Times your papers reporting
that President Trump refused
used to accept a potential recusal from
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions as
far as the Russia investigation what are
the implications here as far as
obstruction of justice and collusion
which seem to be the main prongs of
Robert Muller's investigation I think
the the biggest question from that
reporting this week Mike Michael Schmidt
is did the president try to obstruct
justice that's really the the main
question here it's a huge legal question
it's one that we've seen in the past
lead to impeachment hearings so I think
that that is one of the things that we
really need to look in the on the radar
in the next few weeks whether or not
that reporting is collaborated and
whether or not the DOJ starts digging
into it it sounds like there might be
more of a case to be made if you're
Muller on the obstruction of justice
exact rather than that exactly Russia I
think that right now the clearest
reporting that we have does show a White
House that's really been trying to stop
this investigation that has been trying
to do whatever it can to prevent
hearings in this matter at the same time
as we heard Jeff Pigasus report the
Justice Department is actively
investigating the Clinton Foundation
whether donors got preferential
treatment while Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State this isn't the first
time the Foundation's been investigated
so so what's going on here you know I
think that given the fact that there
doesn't seem to be new evidence on the
table the only conclusion we can come to
is that this is a political vendetta
brought on by the White House you know I
think that the president has made it
clear that he wants the Clintons to be
investigated over and over again over
the past year but you know the White
House me the FBI looked into these
allegations in 2016 and said there
wasn't enough evidence to actually bring
charges so what's new now both speaking
of political football back and forth we
know the president and some of his top
Republican leadership are meeting at
Camp David to discuss the 2018
legislative agenda immigration is a
football that has been tossed back and
forth here the White House seems
unrelenting in its desire to have a
border wall what is the future for young
dreamers and those affected by the the
ending of daca you know I don't I think
the president has suggested that he
would like to find a path for
for the dreamers but the border wall is
one of the things that he said has to be
part of that deal you know that's a
non-starter for Democrats and I think
that you know what we really need here
is a compromise and you know this is a
group of talented young people that
America really can't afford to lose so
it would really be wonderful to see the
White House find a solution that
everyone can live with we will see how
that all plays out Kathleen Kingsbury
with the New York Times thanks for your
time thank you